This is "The Economics of IKEA,"...
...a look at the innovative business practices that have transformed modern life.
When you step into an IKEA,...
...you immediately are put into this maze-like path of different rooms.
IKEA's store layout is a fixed path design,...
...which means there's a designated road...
...that all customers must follow that guides you through the store in one direction.
It's not a grab a carton of milk and get out kind of store.
It's the opposite of that.
It's very much set up to spend a day, think about rooms,...
...dream about what you really want your bedroom to look like.
The floor plan of most IKEA stores resembles a maze...
...that curves about every 50 feet to keep customers curious about what comes next.
Since an average IKEA store is around 300,000 square feet,...
...or five American football fields, that means a lot of walking.
An IKEA is, to some, frustratingly winding,...
...but really it's laid out as an experience to get you to buy more.
IKEA is famous for putting its customers to work.
Unlike most furniture retailers that sell products preassembled,...
...many of IKEA's pieces have to be built by their customers.
But why?
As many couples and their therapists well know,...
...building your own IKEA cabinet can be challenging.
The big idea behind the IKEA effect...
...is consumers are more attached to have more positive feelings...
...towards objects or things that we've put effort into...
...and that we actually think that they're more valuable because of that.
The term "IKEA effect" was first coined in 2011 by researchers...
...who noticed a similar phenomena in other products and businesses.
When instant cake mixes were first introduced in the 1950s,...
...they didn't sell well.
And then they said, let's add a fresh egg.
It was this idea that we want to feel like we're just participating enough...
...to not feel guilty about taking a shortcut.
When you make a cake from a mix, which do you want, a fresh egg cake...
...or a cake made with dried eggs for higher, lighter, tastier cake?
Why, fresh eggs, of course.
The idea that we should love building products isn't necessarily what IKEA intended.